That's the biggest star ball.
And they have an idea who that person is.
Like Kevin Lee's a perfect example, right?
He bought this great guy, super smart,
super tuned in, super ambitious fucking
amazing fighter and young shit. Yeah.
Massive, massive potential. But
people saw him on the podcast,
got to hear him talk for three hours
and he's super honest about everything
about and articulate, articulate, smart
and great control of his ego. He's not,
he's not a maniac. He's a like a
really? Yeah. Cause you get sound bytes,
you get such a different
impression of certain things,
especially in those interviews, man.
Those interviews, the guys like Tomi,
what going to do to your opponent?
I'm gonna fuck him.
I'll be talking about why when I
rubbed off the scale and I'm like,
the energizer is like, what are you
gonna do to him? You're all aggressive,
you know, playing a care, you know,
who would grow even bigger as a superstar
if they did a pocket. Your podcast.
Who? Conor McGregor. Oh, you have
sat down with her while I'm just, no,
I think you would get less hate biopsy.
He has all the accolades in the world,
but, and there's the the stool
or the Dolly, all that shit,
but as a person and he sat
down and you talked to him,
you just didn't get all that Hoopla over
here and he sat down and talked to him.
Oh, I think he'd be, even when
he retires, don't get that. Why?
We almost did it before.
There was some,
some trying to figure out times
like before he became gigantic,
before the Diaz fight, before he won
the title. There was some talk about it.
It just, you know what man?
For better or for worse,
I don't chase anybody and I
would definitely say no, no, no.
I'm not saying you aren't. Oh No, but I'm
saying, I know there's some great guests.
Like I know, I know there's some people
that I would really like to get on,
but if it doesn't happen,
it doesn't happen.
I like having you guys on as much as I
like some scientists who flies in from
France. I really do. I just like, I
like talking to people that are fun.
Whether it's talking to you guys are
talking to share whoever the fuck it is.
I would like to get Obama on one day.
I would like to talk to him
like you're getting huge.
Maybe I would like to talk to a lot of
people. And you like to get Trump on.
I would talk to him. Yeah, why? Why not?
Are you going to get real answers though?
That's a finding as he's the president,
you know,
you'll find out if you get real cause
did you talk to mayor? Have you,
have you talked to me about when you
had Obama on not to submit a list of
questions that the, okay. The questions
and even, you know, he goes, listen,
it was great and I'm glad
to give him the time,
but that's not like a real podcast,
right?
There can be an agenda and I can't
know what I'm going to ask you next.
I come home like when we come on here,
fight campaigns,
there are podcasts that I have no agenda.
I have no idea where we're going
to talk about. They have to be,
they have to be concerned that you're
gonna set them up and make them look bad.
You know what I mean? There's so
much on the line for everything.
And when Obama was doing this,
Obama was a sitting president,
he was about to leave office,
you know,
and they probably had very
strict rules in terms of what,
what they would allow and not
allow in terms of interviews.
And this isn't the platform for it.
I did.
He think Trump doesn't
give a fuck about all that.
I guarantee you he would be more confident
and more open to just being able to
figure his way through it because
he wouldn't worry about, he shoots,
he doesn't prepare for
style. So I wouldn't worry
about me outmaneuvering him.
Like he's not, he's not gonna to do. But
also, have you ever heard Trump before?
He was present on Stern. Yeah. There's
some of the greatest interviews.
He's hilarious. He was great. And,
but even, but he's also older,
you know,
and then also the pressure that Gig and
then the pressure of everybody hating
them. Yeah. You know,
the whole thing is fine.
And I'm not saying this that he's
the greatest guy in the world,
but I'm saying the whole thing is insane.
Nobody should be president
fucking thankless job.
Nobody should have that
kind of power and to,
it's such a dumb move to take
that Gig at 70 it seems to me,
it's like decision you make. You piss off
50% of the people and you make 50% cat.
How much time are you going to win?
How much time do you have left?
What do you have 20 years left?
If everyone cherry on the Sunday for a
guy like that was accomplished with his
ego, but also to say, hey, you have
four years to accomplish all this.
I foc 40 this year.